cette petite blague lanouf à l'est mon
but est atteint nous en faire une bien
sûr je pourrais même vouloir faire
prêter groupe hec une petite souris qui
a envie de sortir de son trou et au
moment où elle sort elle voit le chat
elles rentrent dans le trou une heure
après à l'entendre ou asie ya un chien
chat n'est pas là elle sort et le chat
et la trappe
et pendant qu'ils la mouche de chaïbia
son fils tu vois c'est important les
langues étrangères qui ont connu une
tape jamais la grosse rigolade on
concentre à jamais la gauche c'est un
mec un brave paysan cachette un jour
voilà pour améliorer il achète une
tronçonneuse à voilà dans un comice
agricole lâchait telle méfier avec sept
tronçons deux là vous avez coupé au
moins 10 à faire l'émission
le mec il dit puis à 10 heures par jour
serait ça me changer la vie et le seuil
le jeu il parie
il revient sa fable wii ou à sa femme le
soir il dit alors tu en as coupé combien
je n'ai coupé un champ non je suis et
fusées du spa possible qu'on t'a fait je
n'ai pas j'y retourne demain sera aussi
certainement demain quand il revient il
en a coupé 2 elle n'en peux plus je me
fais courte 1 le week end sur on y
retourne voir le vendeur est née
comtesse pas possible j'ai été deux
trois jours de suite j'ai pu en couper
deux et demi maximum d'arbres
il expose aussi pour tancer ils marchent
merveilleusement cet appareil dans le
monde-- progrès prend la tronçonneuse
belgique est ce que c'est que ce bruit
[Rires]
non mais c'est là qu'on voit
il faut quand même des mecs qui ont du
talent sont bien raconté peu drôle j'ai
tout fait sans merci je veux pas aux
risques sur les roues l'épaule petit à
vous allez rire chaline propres alors
c'est ça se passe dans une dans une
entreprise et il ya les galeries qui dit
coûtera 12 suicides en france donc il
dit il dit à son patron j'ai pu j'ai
très très bien la tête très très mal à
la tête
et donc mes patrons lui répondit mais
moi quand j'ai mal à la tête je rentre
chez moi et je demande à ma femme de me
faire une petite une petite gâterie à
très bien mais je vais essayer ou qui il
a mal à la tête
il s'en va il n'aura prix revient il
voit son bateau dit ça a très bien
marché
patron en plus c'est bien décorée chez
vous le problème c'est que les blacks
sont bonnes mais sont jetés en pâture
allez-y oui à l'essai bonne après midi
la toute première histoire drôle qu'on
m'a raconté sa mèche pardon à nos amis
belges
il est si devant un disquaire et bien je
me mettrais bien la musique une fois
qu'ils pouvaient prendre 7 septembre il
rencontre vidéo disquaires monsieur je
voudrais m'essayer à la musique une fois
oui très bien il ya des instruments qui
nous intéresse oui celui ci celui ci
celui ci celui ci celui ci très bien et
est ce que je peux laisse emporter tout
ça dépend de ce que parce que le tube à
l'harmonica l'accordéon et la trompette
oui vous pouvez le prendre tout de suite
mais le radiateur faut quelques jours
pour le démonter
voir et il faut arrêter il faut rester
bien en cours de la dernière sa mère
ouverte à petit après away jallet
plaindre et à rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est
c'est une question c'est où vont
s'amuser les petite biscotte
oui à charge un sens mal c'est le alors
au chili où aller en discothèque
[Musique]
mais je vais vous dire oh moi je sais
que je suis pas trompé ça me rassure
c'est très drôle
un bis cotec c13 souri à des souris à la
main sourire et ça raccroche les trois
souris les deux premières ça contraire
elle dit moi quand je veux du fromage je
vais dans l'appât je soulève la page je
prends le fromage est aux anges
les deux audi mais t'as pas peur dit moi
j'ai pas peur il sourit la deuxième est
débattue celle de quoi je me nourris moi
je me nourris des petits grains rouge
mais c'est dire si du poison et des gens
mangent tous les matins à 3 m à savais
pas quoi dire et des bancs à il est 14
heures je vous laisse faut que j'aille
n'est qu'un char
[Rires]
drôle